hello everyone I am Felipe Hoffa a
Google cloud platform developer advocate
and today I'm at the gate have offices
to learn about how they are using
bigquery you might already know that
beaker is great when you want to analyze
terabytes of data in seconds and there
are a lot of open datasets around that
you can query whenever you want but
macquaire is not only good for open data
a lot of corporations enterprise's
companies are using bigquery to
understand their own data their users
their own metrics etc and today I could
have I'm going to look at both walls
because we have a lot at least three
open data sets about github and that
they are using to understand their own
company so today Allison la from the
data science team at github will join me
and we will explore how they are using
bigquery and other tools and open data
to understand their own organization so
Allison thank you so much for inviting
me
thanks yes and I know you've done great
stuff here at it have and before we get
started I wanted to mention to everyone
how you been doing awesome stuff like I
went to the github universe conference
and you publish these github October's
and you were behind it yeah so I was
part of a cross-departmental team that
helped publish this infographic if you
will all about the state of the
October's and it has a few different
sections but one of the sections is
focused on open source and it was really
important to me to be able to publish
those open source metrics using the open
data set and be able to publish the
queries behind it for the community to
reuse nice so you have that October here
and have a lot of different open source
analysis but before we get to how you
made it I would love to know how you got
started in this world absolutely so I
got started about four years ago I was
one of the first accountants at github
actually and when I started I had never
seen a terminal before or seen code at
all but I was really curious so
asked a lot of questions to my
co-workers and started going to meetups
and eventually got to learn how to code
a little bit and using my analysis
skills as an accountant and Excel and
hacking skills that I learned from going
off to all these meetups I was able to
parlay that into a position on our data
science team as an analyst nicely you
start as an accountant you started going
to meetups like and so all around the
Bay Area
there's meetups for example women who
code and there's rails bridge on the
weekends and rails girls need ups where
I was able to make some apps and then
also by searching github and seeing
projects I was able to fork them and
clone them and learn how to hack that
way so working as an accompaniment have
you were able to find open benefits
about github and that turned you into a
data person data analyst that is really
cool and what kind of open benefits do
you have available so the open datasets
that I've used on bigquery there's a few
different ones so first there's the
github archive yeah which is all of the
event data so every single time someone
stars or pushes or create the issue
comment or a pull request that's
recorded as an as an event and so that's
one data set it's called the github
archive and then another data set is the
github public data set that you help
publish yeah that's a great one it's all
the contents of all of the repositories
and that one's different from the events
data because it's only repositories that
have a detectable open-source license
for open source projects that we know to
be open source we have taken them and
putting them on bigquery all of it
constant the code so I've been able to
run analysis like hey do we have more
tabs or spaces where it's more problem
really cool and we are now having a
third data set agh torrent that's a
different project that does a pretty
nice job of making the all citrate
or like you have out kind of like we
have all of the events but with the 8
story we are able to see everything like
in different tables normalized so see
for example where are people coming from
what country do they come from
yeah so the gh torrent includes the
geographic data and all of the data sets
are really complementary so it's really
nice that they're all in one place on
bigquery and anyone can come to bigquery
Family Services start doing joins
between them yeah just to show everyone
what kind of queries around can you show
me a little bit of yeah so we can start
by looking at the octave verse and the
queries that power the open source
section nice so here's the Octobers yeah
so for example this graph was pretty
popular of the 15 most popular languages
on github by open pull request and the
percent changed from the previous period
I published the queries that go along
with this so here's the example of the
most popular languages by pull request
it's using a JSON extract of the events
payload so that's an important element
on the agate have archive data set we
have a lot of they think or the jason
that's right we can do that with
unstructured data we kind of storage a
saw so we don't have to think about
columns when we're storing data and now
you need to write queries like this that
extract data from jason yeah yeah so
just by using the JSON extract and then
using you know a timestamp and choosing
the date range and this is a 12 month
date range was able to do get this
output of you know say at the top 25
languages and then changing the date
range to compare it against the previous
time period
so as you publish these queries anyone
can come to github take these queries
copy them into bigquery and start
running their own analysis exactly
starting by with your query exactly so
ok you have we have these queries Oh yep
they are exposed and this queries when
actually inside the query the the web UI
ok what can you tell me about the web UI
how do you use it oh yeah so going to
the Google bigquery there's a couple
different places where you can
see the different data sets so here is
the github archive data set and it has
these different table structures and
then the bigquery public data set is
here and under github repos is where you
can find all of the tables that are the
repositories that we talked about the
file contents
yes I hearing you have ripoff I have in
the content table that's a huge table if
you click on it I think it's a s'more if
you click on details yes 1.7 1.9
terabytes of data now and then on geek
America we have all of the events and we
have them organized by day month year
yeah that where are you yeah so if we go
back to this gist you can just copy and
paste this into the UI here on bigquery
and it'll know to pull up this github
archive date table so we can run that
query and you're running everything
between 2015 so one one year one year of
data by day and this query goes over a
lot of date yeah and especially with the
extract of the payload to pull out the
repo based language and also we're doing
an extract of the JSON payload to make
sure that it's only the action equals
opened mm-hmm so it's only counting pull
requests once by when they're opened
nice here we already found what were the
most popular languages last year yeah
for the state range then we have the
output of the language name and the
count of the total poor request by
language so a reminder for everyone that
wants to play with this data hey we're
here we looked at a full year of data
body and before we give you a free
terabyte of wearing to run your queries
every month now if you want to make
those queries that total of longer
instead of playing the full year when
you're playing go for a few days yeah
and then just go over yeah before yeah
exactly so
doing exploratory analysis I usually
limit it to maybe seven days or two
weeks and then when I'm ready to look
over the full date range that I want to
analyze then I'll open it up to the full
date range we analyzed about 600 600
years of data at the seconds parsing
JSON in the mean time that's pretty cool
yeah that's a great tool nice and then
you were able to take these these that
had these queries and visualize them
yeah yes that was a visual designer that
did all of the pretty visualizations in
the October but I've done visualizations
separately in other side projects using
the github archive public data set in
tableau and then also more more recently
I'm using looker nice how you use
tableau and then we can jump to the
project that I did using tableau was
called open source monthly and
internally we want to just take a look
at what was going on in our organization
and the repositories within the github
organization the public repositories
that is so I was able to connect tableau
directly with bigquery and pull in the
events data and start to do some
analysis looking at what are the most
active repositories within the whole org
who are the most active contributors
contributing to the org and what is the
most common event type whether that's an
issue being created or a star or a fork
and just kind of get the overall view of
what's going on within the organization
in an open source nice you're publishing
this with about tableau public now yeah
that's right so this is all public so
okay so taking a look at the github
organization for so this is connected on
a monthly basis so November 2015 is when
I did this project yeah I know one year
later it's showing that you know the
most common event type is star for the
for our org Cuba our robot is the most
active contributor
[Music]
exactly and then this is a they call
them tree maps or tree graphs of the
rectangle equals the size of the amount
of events going on in that repository
our get ignore repository is super
active as far as events and then get LFS
and then our get Hugh bot for this month
how do you create these reports with
that long so I created using the tableau
workbook which I have on my desktop and
I can do a direct connect to Google
bigquery I just have to click Google
bigquery and enter my credentials and
sign in and then allow access and then
so once I've connected my tableau
workbook with bigquery I will be able to
see that it's connected this server here
and I can select a project here are the
public datasets that we can look at but
to access that you have archive I just
type in github archive enables a
brilliant answer that effect yeah and
then scroll down and look at the data
set that I want to use so I want to use
the month mm-hmm and I can scroll down
to get the most recent complete month
which would be September here and I can
drag that over and update and this is
like doing you know a select star limit
ten where I can see the output of the
table and just kind of overview what's
in the table contents and then from here
I can go to the worksheet and start
dragging and dropping to do some
exploratory analysis using tableau
tableau understands all of the columns
you have here and yeah it already knows
the dates should be in a date format
boolean czar true/false numbers strings
so for example if you I want to know the
most frequent event yeah so I could just
select type and a number of Records and
do show me bar chart and just to get an
overview I can see
if I filter this down that push events
are the most common events for this
month followed by create events watch
events and issue comments and if you
want to filter these events yeah so you
can slice and dice that a couple
different ways you can you know drag the
or glog in here to filter and from there
it will allow you to choose say I can
choose Google as the name of the
organization on github and the
organization that's great now we can see
how people are interacting with these
projects yeah exactly
so these are the different events
triggered filtered specifically on the
login for the Google organization you
can see it's a different shape here
before it was mostly push events and the
most common event type for the Google
organization is a watch event which is
considered starring yeah and here you
can keep drilling me you can look at the
most popular projects what people are
doing you see not only tableau here
that's right so recently I got started
using looker which is also an analysis
tool tool similar to tableau but the
nice thing about looker is it allows you
to do a data connection to bigquery
but then build a model layer where it
allows you to basically do pre joins if
you want to do it you can do the JSON
extract directly in the model layer and
we love it because it's all version
controlled using github so taking a look
here is an example dashboard using the
github archive latest events so again
using a short date range this is
filtered just the last two days this is
an example of the dashboard that you can
use to see them the number of active
users the number of active organizations
repositories you know the event types
developers buy commit counts and again
most popular languages here by pull
request account and then you can filter
to any organization you want so say we
can look at angular here and see on the
dashboard that in this
period of two days there were 530 active
users anyone that interacted with any
repositories on the angular organization
65 actor repositories and then you can
see that the most popular languages by
pull requests are a little bit different
JavaScript typescript HTML Java and the
interesting thing about Luke is that it
has a layer where Luca understands what
the underlying that ice yeah so I can
show you that model layer okay it's a
model that someone have to write that's
right but only one person at the
organisation needs to understand I think
it helps for other people to understand
the model and how how it's built
but not everyone needs to know how to
write on the model layer
good perhaps more though yeah so this is
the model for all of the public events
and lookers really neat because it has
this IDE where it tells you what you
have not committed yet so these green
lines are things that I still need to
push up there's a good cup music I can
just press commit changes and it will
push it up to the hosted git repository
on github but for example this pull
request action here I can do this JSON
extract here and then I can filter on
the action so when I go to do the
analysis I can just pick action equals
opened or closed and allows me to you
know pick out the pre-filter and do the
JSON extract here so anyone that's
working with Luca doesn't need to
understand that the some data if encoder
yeah the model takes care of abstracting
that away yeah that's really cool what a
lot of people ask me is how to translate
these interesting metrics into
actionable advice like what kind of
things can you do that translate into
actions yeah so something we're thinking
about internally is open source KPIs or
key performance indicators using the
github bigquery data sets so things like
open source monthly active users or
monthly active repositories and tracting
tracking that over time phalion we can
look at people by region how they are
interacting with the it path yeah so
another way to measure user engagement
is looking at monthly active users and
daily active users and seeing the ratio
by region to see where some users are
less engaged than others and just really
by region how different regions are
using github differently so this is
really really awesome I love how anyone
at home can start writing their own
queries finding the status phase and
other public data sets any advice for
someone that wants to start on this path
yeah so my advice would be to check out
the published queries you have some out
floating around the internet there's
some in the gist that I linked in the
October's all of those things here yeah
check out the links below and then also
check out the developer Docs where you
can learn about the different event
types and the payloads so you can
understand exactly what's going on there
nice so we have everything documented we
have sample queries we have some plan a
leafy yeah and now it's up to you to
start working with this and for you
please start trying out B query find
open data set remember that you have a
monthly terabyte at no cost to run your
own queries check all of the resources
we left on this video description and
I'm out for today thank you very much
and stay curious
thank you everything thank you